Diese neue Entdeckung eines internationalen
Forschungsteams könnte ganz neue Anwendungsmöglichkeiten
eröffnen.
Beispielsweise könnten Hightech-Materialien
von Computern und Smartphones enorm verbessert
werden.
Denn Fachleute aus Spanien und den USA haben
jetzt ganz neue Eigenschaften von Licht aufgespürt.
Konkret konnten sie sogenanntes “Korkenzieher-Licht”
produzieren, dessen Bahndrehimpuls sich mit
der Zeit verändert.
Lichtstrahlen also, die eher einem Croissant
als einem Korkenzieher ähneln.
Das Licht diese Eigenschaft besitzt, ist tatsächlich
eine Sensation!
Clixoom Science & Fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, - abonniert den
Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich
willkommen!
Um eines direkt am Anfang mal klarzustellen:
Licht ist nicht gleich Licht!
Erst, wie wir Menschen durch unsere technischen
Möglichkeiten mit dem Licht umgehen und seine
Eigenschaften manipulieren, können wir es
als vielseitiges Mittel zum Zweck nutzen.
Was ich damit meine: Die Polarisation des
Lichts beispielsweise wird durch die Schwingungsrichtung
beeinflusst; die Energie und Wellenlänge
der Strahlung entscheidet dagegen über die
Lichtfarbe.
Auch, wie sich die Lichtteilchen - auch Photonen
genannt - bewegen, ist entscheidend.
In Laserstrahlen beispielsweise geschieht
dies im Gleichtakt.
Eine weitere Eigenschaft von Licht ist extrem
spannend.
Und zwar ist vom sogenannten Bahndrehimpuls
- im Englischen: “Orbital Angular Momentum”
(OAM) die Rede.
In der Fachsprache wird damit die Eigenschaft
von Licht bezeichnet, die besonders exotische
Strahlformen hervorbringt.
Die Lichtwelle dreht sich bei ihrer Ausbreitung
somit spiralig um ihre eigene Achse.
Dieses Licht wird auch als “Korkenzieher-Licht”
bezeichnet und das macht seinem Namen alle
Ehre.
Schließlich ist die Rede von einer schraubenförmigen
Welle.
Ein spanisches Forschungsteam konnte jetzt
in Experimenten beweisen, dass sich dieser
OAM variieren lässt.
Denn sie entdeckten nun Lichtstrahlen, deren
Bahndrehimpuls sich mit der Zeit ändert.
Dazu heißt es in der aktuellen Studie: “Im
Prinzip kann man sich diese exotischen Lichtpulse
als eine Abfolge von Photonen vorstellen,
deren Bahndrehimpuls sich jeweils gegenüber
dem Vorgänger erhöht”.
Die Metapher des Korkenziehers oder der Schraube
hat somit also ausgedient.
Das Forschungsteam selbst vergleicht die Lichtstrahlen
eher mit der Form eines Croissants.
Es entsteht ein Effekt, den die Fachleute
als “Self-Torque” bezeichnen.
Das bedeutet quasi so etwas wie “Selbstverdrillung”,
was tatsächlich auch schon in anderen Systemen
der Physik zu beobachten ist - beispielsweise
in der Elektrodynamik und auch in der Allgemeinen
Relativitätstheorie.
Dennoch die aktuelle Entdeckung eine kleine
Sensation, denn das auch Licht diese Eigenschaft
besitzt, war bislang unbekannt.
Die Entdeckung gelang dem spanischen Forschungsteam
zunächst nur durch die Analyse theoretischer
Modelle; später dann aber auch der Nachweis
in der Praxis.
Die Modelle legten nahe, dass sich OAM-Licht
erzeugen lassen müsste, das eine solche verändernde
Windungsdichte hat.
Zudem ließen die Modelle auch den Schluss
zu, auf welche Art und Weise der “Self-Torque”-Effekt
nachzuweisen ist.
Möglich wird dieser Nachweis nämlich durch
den sogenannten “Frequenz-Chirp” - einer
Veränderung der Frequenz im Lichtkorkenzieher.
Denn dieser Chirp umgewandelt in hörbare
Frequenzen würde im menschlichen Gehör einen
abfallenden oder ansteigenden Ton bedeuten.
Doch das alles ist viel einfacher gesagt als
getan.
Dazu der US-Forscher Kevin Dorney: “Zunächst
hat uns dies einiges Kopfzerbrechen bereitet.
Denn schon das OAM-Licht zu erzeugen ist alles
andere als trivial.“
Doch die Experimente gelangen tatsächlich.
Die Fachleute erzeugten zwei Strahlen von
Korkenzieherlicht, die sich in nur einem Bahndrehimpuls
unterscheiden.
Durch deren Überlagerung in einer sich überschall-schnell
ausdehnenden Wolke aus Argongas gelang dem
Forschungsteam der Erfolg.
Denn so entstand tatsächlich Licht mit Self-Torque:
Strahlen von energiereichen UV-Licht - charakterisiert
durch sich verändernde Schraubenwindungen.
Die Änderung der Windungsdichte gelang in
der Praxis also genau wie in den theoretischen
Modellen vorhergesagt: durch die Erzeugung
eines veränderlichen Tons.
Eine kleine Sensation.
Dazu die verantwortliche Forscherin Laura
Rego: “Dies ist das erste Mal, dass jemand
diese neue Eigenschaft des Lichts theoretisch
beschrieben und sogar beobachtet hat.
Damit haben wir demonstriert, dass Lichtstrahlen
mit zeitabhängigem Bahndrehimpuls erzeugt
werden können.“
Somit gelang es den Fachleuten also, eine
neue Eigenschaft von Licht aufzuspüren.
Und das Ganze ist nicht nur interessant für
die Grundlagenphysik.
Es eröffnen sich auch neue spannende Anwendungsmöglichkeiten,
denn Materialien und Moleküle auf Nanoebene
könnten so auf ihre dynamische Struktur untersucht
werden.
Interessant ist das vor allem in Hinblick
auf Hightech-Materialien für Smartphones
und Computer.
Extrem spannende Aussichten für die Zukunft!
In die schaut ja Doktor Whatson regelmäßig
und erklärt Wie man Licht kontrollieren kann
Unbedingt anklicken, unbedingt anschauen und
unbedingt Doktor Whatson abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!